[Music]
you had me doing this during your
interview with Jota like I was blinking
ripped his fall she starts it by giving
you the debug and you know what it means
and it's but it is not true I wanted to
talk about and it's I didn't want to
like have to ugly cry but you know what
and you can't stop it if you feel that
it's it's there and it's a good thing to
talk about it got me in the gut just
thinking about like what a child has
done for your life you look back in your
life you know I've had a really good
life but once you have children you go
my life was nothing until you showed up
I mean I was wasting time literally
wasting time every day until they showed
up and now I know exactly what my life
is about because of them it's so close I
just want to hold on a job make some
friends
[Music]
yeah pay my bills I love that we're
finally gonna get to see this baby born
I mean this is really a cool moment
because I love the movie so much and I
know there's been a lot made about it
but I didn't get to ask you this before
is very ocean then again yes yet we
don't know what listen can anyone really
kill off Danny ocean really I killed him
off once in one movie I can't kill them
all twice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]